in the aftermath of Diddy's surprise
baby announcement I want to get it right
young Miami seemingly sharing her
reaction on Twitter why you want to say
you want to talk yeah fans were talking
after the music mogul shocked fans on
Saturday firing off the news on social
media quote I'm so blessed to welcome my
baby girl love Sean Combs to the world
no baby pics for now but et's learned
the mother is Dana Tran and she's
reportedly a cyber security specialist
Diddy's previously been linked with
young Miami also known as karisha fast
forward two days later she's speaking
out while we can say whether karisha's
Twitter Firestorm on Monday is related
there's plenty to speculate about the
timing shout out to deities about him
tonight and one tweet she writes quote
I'm nobody side blank let's just make
this clear on this good Monday another
tweet quote I'm not mad I'm trending
Miami's clap back also comes after pics
of Diddy out on a date with a third
woman from October surfaced this week I
watch our relationship studies
Mr at bed
I'm single you know
I'm single but I'm dating I'm just
taking my time with life check out Diddy
and Miami chatting on the first episode
of her podcast in June I get advice from
karisha you know what I'm saying karisha
tell me like yo don't don't be in your
head and you know you're just a good
friend everybody that's a friend of
yours will tell you like that you're a
great friend and although he initially
responds by saying he's single she gets
right to the point so what we is
we date
we dating
we go have dates we're friends
we go to Exotic locations
we have great times we go to strip clubs
Church
Church
I'm gonna take you to church
I love it besides having a good time
Diddy explains how they've connected on
a deeper level
because you're authentic
you know you're like one of the realest
people I ever met you know what I'm
saying and you know authentically
yourself
and your great mother and you know
a great friend you just have a good time
so no other relationship updates for now
but Diddy's probably got his hands full
with his seventh bundle of joy he's
father to four children he shared with
the late comporter Quincy King and twins
Jesse and Delilah Diddy also shares
Justin with Misa Hilton and chance with
Sarah Chapman
[Applause]
is he caught up with chance and Diddy at
the Oscars first of all the biggest
thing that's going on tonight is me
bringing my daughter to this because
she's an aspiring actress and we get to
have a date and I'm just so excited I
wish you were dealing with Daddy
emotionally when she walked out yeah
right right what did you say what did
you do what the [ __ ] is going on right
[Applause]
I love it there's gonna have to be some
hard conversations coming up no no he's
they know what's up
[Music]